brüderle guten morgen wir machen
so schnell kann's gehen
da redet man über fragen jetzt habe ich
mit rein kommen weiß ich nicht welche
angemeldet sie hier
ihr pressesprecher hat es uns verboten
jetzt habe ich ja ewig in die
veranstaltung muss auch das presse
statement warten
von daher mache ich mir derzeit einfach
mal selbst ein bild und geht mit alters
die hinter künstler fühlen dass jährlich
da sind emma ihre sachen und der applaus
kleinste heute und wenn das löschen was
aber ganz schön viel eher das muss so
und jetzt gesellschaft steht sehr gut
[Musik]
mehr
sein
würden sie einem jungen menschen raten
pfleger zu werden ist ein harter arbeit
alltag den sie so auf der linie 34 für
familien noch geplant werden schon
wieder geworden
[Musik]
aber ich muss sagen schon anstrengend
ich glaube ich kann besser unterhaltung
wenn sie mein hallo berlin seid ihr gut
drauf ja ich fange direkt mit dem
klassiker an kennen sie bestimmt alle
kommt ein pferd ende war sagt der
barkeeper warum das lange gesichter nach
dem auflegen
da habe ich direkt noch einen für euch
wie nennt man einen reichen pfleger erbe
der ist hintergründig sie haben so fasst
okay einen habe ich noch woran erkennt
man rainer brüderle im fernsehen an den
untertitel das was von mir vielen dank
berlin
danke ja ich weiß halt wie man laden zum
kochen bringt und jetzt geht's noch mal
zum brüderle die beschäftigten bescheid
wenn jedes jahr mehr beschäftigt den
privaten unternehmen gehen das ist deren
entscheidung aus gute überlegung aus was
würden sie sagen ist cleverer wenn die
pflegeversicherung einzahlen oder
einfach direkt in heim- investieren und
dann davon der rendite richten sie mal
herr belge herzliche grüße aus nachdem
er eine sehr lange sommerpause genommen
hat würden glück auf für seine weiter
sehe ja jetzt sind wir wieder da und sie
sind ja auf den gebieten echter experte
eine koryphäe sie kennen sich wirklich
sehr gut aus
deswegen meine frage welchen wein soll
ich kaufen
dabei machen sie gute sendungen
produzieren sich hat tiefer bist auf dem
bildschirm und strengen sich an die show
wieder zu ich habe das gefühl sie haben
wenn ich richtig zu
aber das passt ja auch zum thema pflege
du kannst du dir auch nicht da darf ich
rainer brüderle doch noch fragen stellen
und er redet beim thema pflege nur über
welche aber uli lass dir nichts sagen so
alt bist du noch nicht und denn was ist
ich bin für dich da
und damit zurück ins studio
[Musik]